all right read with me the marks on a
test are normally distributed so there's
the key phrase for you to know that our
nice symmetrical bell curve and all of
those percentages we just mentioned
they're relevant so I'm just gonna I
like that they have a mean of 65 and a
standard deviation of 8 okay so it
begins with some nice easy stuff let's
have a look here what mark is one
standard deviation above above and one
standard deviation below the mean so
this is part one the way I would write
this can I encourage you I know it's
kind of easy just to go to the numbers
but there's going to be lots of numbers
here and I want to know what on earth
they refer to so I'm just going to write
what it is they're asking this is what
this is this is the way to do it before
it so it's not part of the exercise but
I'd love you to walk it along with me
okay so the mean is X bar so once then
deviation below that is X bar take away
one standard deviation so I'm going to
write that so I know what in my head
these numbers actually mean we've been
told what each of those numbers is it's
65 take away eight and we can do that
perhaps right that's 57 I think if you
added a which we're about to do if we go
also out yet no actually you're right
I've done it the wrong way that's this
one sorry you're right we're meant to
add for the first part so I'll get X bar
plus the standard deviation and this
time it's 65 plus 8 which is 73 okay so
now I knew the range from below one
standard deviation to above so now you
can see why they talk about it like
what's the relevance of B what
proportion of students is between these
two marks well this is the first graph
that I gave you right what proportion of
students what percentage is between yeah
it's 68% so I would just say 68% of
you can also say because I recognize
what's going on it's as in scarf - 1 vs
n score of 1 this is written like this
so that's a bit of a weed way to say it
but I want you to recognize if you see
it sometimes I think actually it's less
than or equal to it you can see that
what this means is if you have a z-score
that's between negative 1 and 1 that
means you have a roll mark between 57
and 73 that means you're in the 68% does
that make sense so sometimes you see
these CDs read lesser than greater than
signs that's all they mean between
negative 1 and 1
ok then they asked you to go further now
should you go further so for Part C oh
right there's both supposed to go in the
same direction because the idea is that
for the left-hand side right
you've got Z on the bigger side than
negative 1 right so it's like negative 1
negative 0.9 negative point-eight etc so
you're bigger than that so that's why
the greater than sign is on this side
and 4 when you're comparing it to 1 we
mean 0.3 0.4 0.5 that's less than 1 so
that is still on this side does that
make sense
ok this time for part I kept doing it
for Part C they just want us to go
further you guys two standard deviations
away so this is X bar plus two of them
right so that's 65 plus 1/16 very good
so that looks to me like it's 81 anyone
and 4 pots ooh it looks like they wants
to go below so instead of adding 16 I'm
going to take it away
65 take away 16 that's going to be so
now we can see between 49 and 81 much
bigger range so that's why Part D asks
what proportion of students is that it's
to send deviations so what percentage
ninety-five okay so I'm going to stop
there because you get the trend now how
far away do you have to go so now if the
students said do you see how the z-score
is powerful if from your point of view
for your point of view you find out
generally the mean right you guys all
ask me what's the average I know what my
score was I know maybe I got I got 73
and then you asked me for the average
and I tell you what the average is but
actually what you should ask me now is
what was my Zed school right because now
you know all right how far away am I
relatively speaking in what proportion
of the Kirk 11 yeah absolutely